este martes las autoridades georgianas
cumplieron su palabra y detuvieron al
opositor mi camelia en la sede de su
partido mientras tanto en la calle
militantes se enfrentaban a los policías
es una imagen sin precedentes para
cualquier país democrático cuando un
número tan grande de policías irrumpe y
las fuerzas especiales irrumpen en el
edificio del principal partido de la
oposición para detener de forma
totalmente ilegal al líder del partido y
de la oposición
melià el líder opositor es acusado de
incitar a la violencia en las protestas
callejeras de junio de 2019 una
acusación que él ha rechazado por
completo el delito que se le imputa
podría llevarlo a una pena de hasta
nueve años de prisión
en ningún caso pueden impedir que el
pueblo georgiano amante de la libertad
proteste este es el final este es el
final del régimen
los regímenes terminan así no mantendrán
el poder con el apoyo de estas fuertes
fuerzas especiales
a la orden de arresto hacia el opositor
provocó la dimisión del primer ministro
jordi ganar ya la semana pasada el lunes
el parlamento de georgia nombró en su
lugar al ministro de defensa y rack y
gary más vil y quien ya había ocupado el
cargo entre 2013 y 2015
amigos míos quiero repetir que en el
menor tiempo posible una de mis primeras
tareas y prioridades será restaurar el
orden constitucional en el país para que
nadie esté por encima de la ley este es
un nuevo capítulo en la crisis política
provocada por las elecciones
parlamentarias de octubre pasado que
según la oposición podrían estar bajo la
sombra de fraude